[Music]
yeah okay thank you it's great to be
here I need to start with - apologies
one is that I'm completely jet-lagged I
just arrived this morning after a
15-hour is a flight and this is that 10
hours difference from where I come from
so I apologize for whatever that's gonna
happen and then the second apology is
that I'm a little bit gonna cheat now
and the reason is it Katrina asked me to
give a broader talk but I'm really
enthusiastic also to share an uncooked
idea so I'm just going to combine the
two and just let's see what happens
so I'm I'm gonna talk about my research
agenda over the past couple of theories
and that is governance by AI and the way
it intersects with democracy
so this combines two interest that they
have both in a lot of computer science
that on the one hand and on the other
hand my concern with the decline of
liberal democracies and in a nutshell I
think that one of the reasons we are
experiencing a crisis in democracies is
that we have moved from governing by
rules to governing by algorithms and
data and the checks and balances that
were built to the gut to safeguarding
our freedom and restraining the power of
states
liberal democracies are actually
tailored for a system that governs by
rules that is doing a completely
different thing and and so I'm going to
talk a little bit about this and about
why I think there is a problem I'm going
to demonstrate this or to focus on a
particular context of content motivation
and the way in which we govern the
public sphere and then I'm going to
offer an unbaked proposal and so so so
this is our plan my interest in this in
in governance and thinking about the way
in which apps are governing or behavior
as actually emerged from my intimate
experience with ways this is an app that
was developed by a startup company in
Israel I have a lot to say about this it
was purchased by Google even the driver
that brought me very early this morning
was using this app and this is the
social navigator how many people are
using this okay so you know society like
Israel where everyone is using this or
in other contexts when everyone is using
these ways is is doing a couple of
things and one is that is really of
interest to us here and that is a way in
which ways is suppose this app is
suppose to find the shortest route for
each of us as drivers to our destination
but what I found myself in many
instances is that I drive on the coast
road in Israel and everyone is driving
using Waze and all of a sudden people
are starting to drive to take another
pass and I'm with and I always wonder
why is it that sometimes I get to take
you know this very you know longer way
and others are getting the free highway
right because all of us had to or some
of us had to go
the other way made me start to think
about the dural role of these apps right
that they're serving not only the
interest of their subscribers but to
some extent they need to maximize the
social welfare of those users right it
doesn't mean that it takes into account
all the social interest and of course in
the context of Wade's are many that have
to suffer from the havoc traffic that
goes through the neighborhoods but it
does have to take into account more than
or to optimize more than my own
interests and and I think in this way we
can also think about social platform
having to mitigate some of the interests
or conflicting interests of a lot of
their users and to some extent some of
the externalities there are inflicting
on others and I'll try to demonstrate
this in the context of content
motivation or the removal of content and
so when we think of these systems
working using making decisions that are
based on the collection of data the
processing of data the prediction and
then the action that follows when we
compare this when we when we think about
these systems as governing our behavior
and we think about the tools that we
have right in liberal democracies for
safeguarding our freedom there might be
some these systems might be incompatible
so what do we have and these are just
this is not an exhaustive list of course
of our checks and balances safeguards
for our freedom but we can think about
civil rights of restraining the
government use of power right if we have
a right then the government
not violate it unless certain conditions
procedural or substantive certainty are
fulfilled we have another principle of
the rule of law where all we would say
that the citizen could like the
principle of legality for instance right
but everyone is allowed free to do
everything that is not prohibited by law
or that the government cannot do
anything that is not authorized by law
right this is another way in which we
govern or limit the use of power by
government and we have separation of
powers where we have a division of labor
but also a division of powers between
the three branches that are competing
with one another assuming that that
could safeguard the freedom of citizens
so when we move to the government's by
data and algorithms in this way that
Facebook is going in our behavior or
public sphere or the ways is governing
the traffic of course there is a problem
of privacy and surveillance this assumes
the 24/7 surveillance the collection of
data the more data you collect the
better if there your governing model
could be but I don't want to talk about
this because all we are going to talk
about this so I was assigned to talk
about issues that are beyond privacy and
let's talk for instance about the way
this is challenging you know somewhere
our fundamental rights so if we have a
presumption of innocence and we normally
think that we should not be stopped if
we are not suspected of anything right
if the police doesn't have the authority
to do that how does it fit with
predictive policing where we actually
want to predict we predicts that we are
going to commit a crime maybe to what
extent our notion of reasonable
suspicion could be a right or civil
right that can actually protect us in
this and
and we can talk about this a little bit
later another problem is that once we
move to governance by AI we're looking
at governance which is happening on
private spaces right the servers of
private companies it is using
proprietary programs that are
intellectual property and therefore
would be beyond or barriers for us to
oversight it and and data that was
discussed in the previous in a warning
session data would be owned by the
platform and I think this is something
that we need to actually take into
consideration where we have a lot of the
focus this morning was about privacy as
a driving force behind restrictions of
the use of data but there is also
ownership right who owns the data and
who can prevent others by the right by
the physical ability to prevent access
to close the API of Facebook but but
also by the legal right to prevent
others from using that data either for
creating their innovation but also for
for allowing the public to oversight
whatever it is that is happening there
and here again what what is really
interesting that when we think about
restraining power in the context of
governmental power we normally would
think about separation of powers right
the and here we look at private
companies I think volunteer is really an
interesting example where you have the
Facebook of police stations that are
actually accumulating data that is used
for various
various methods and applications of
predicting policing and and Palantir is
a private company a lot of the
restraints that we have and the users
governmental power would not apply even
though governments would actually stand
or share their data for processing and
learning by the models of Pollin tier
and then get the prediction and apply it
in the way they are actually using the
resources of the police this is just to
give like I think the bigger context is
tales die also
I thought was missing from our morning
discussion therefore I thought that I
should mention it in this talk is
actually the dis all fits in a market
for data that is very different from the
market set tangible goods in the sense
that this market is based on collecting
the data processing the data creating
these models that are being used for the
smart city is an autonomous car and
personalized medicine and then these
products are actually feeding back into
that model of collecting better and more
data that can actually refine our models
and so those who are into this processor
actually enjoying or benefiting from the
advantage of controlling all of this
data just to give it a context again of
some of the issues that we were
discussing this morning when we were
thinking about targeted advertising we
we talked about the fact that if
facebook allows advertisers to create
their own advertising policy on Facebook
then some of the restrictions that meant
to protect the privacy of users are no
longer useful but at the same time
that would create at least some
competition among the advertisers
working in this ecosystem otherwise
Facebook is actually the only player
because it actually benefit from that
feedback loop that is a big chunk of it
in a one study that we have published
earlier this year we were actually
looking at the way in which this system
is affected by the use or or this market
is affected by the use of data for some
governmental functions that are not
doing are not done by the market like in
Palantir or like the removal of content
that really I will describe in a minute
that is being done by Facebook or
YouTube or the traffic control that
could be done where is done by ways to
some extent but when it is actually done
by the government how introducing the
government when the government want to
use this type of data that is being used
and collected by companies can actually
distort this market and have some bad
fact on the market by reducing the
volume of information that is being
collected but more importantly the
quality of data that is collected and
thereby also affecting the type of
data-driven innovation as it is being
produced by the data and these models
that are based on that data so overall
when we look at innovation by by AI in
this context we really need to
reconfigure some of these checks and
balances we cannot use the same rights
and processes and institutions that are
securing freedom in this environment and
we
we really need to innovate we really
need to think what it is that we want to
protect and what would be the right
institutions processes and and rights
that would protect these values to
simply take fairness or discrimination
and apply it to this environment might
not be useful so let me demonstrate this
in the context of content moderation by
AI and this is definitely a growing
field but not that new it's actually it
is something that has evolved over the
past three decades and it is happening
in in this environment right where we
have platforms that are actually
controlling access to information yeah I
understand where you're coming from
because for me government's I tend to
think of as a government right no I
think governing yeah that's why that's
what I meant by the example of governing
behavior by ways right so ways you can
say well ways it's not governing my
behavior but it does right I mean you
can have you can you can have ways tell
you you know how to drive or where to go
ways can actually tell you where not to
go it can actually block some streets
either because because they think that
it's inappropriate to go in some areas
or because it gets some instructions
from the government these are
governmental functions you know to
control the traffic so it can substitute
for some of the some countries it's
ministries or municipalities that are
doing this type of job and it actually
managed the traffic of a lot of drivers
so this is not like a personal tutor
that is telling you what to do but also
you know
an app that he's taking into cancer in
this sense I mean governing behavior and
in the context of content moderation
that would be governing a public sphere
right deciding what could be what could
we read what canning what type of
information who could read what you know
what would be removed also the checks
and balances you describe maybe that's
exactly the point that's exactly why
it's a problem that the checks and
balances are tailored for a government
that is for states rights and for
government organs that are working but
envision a world where all of these
functions would be done like police by
Palantir content moderation by Facebook
okay so it's great that we have this
bill of right and the checks and
balances but in fact we live in a world
where there are no restraints of power
and that is something that we need to
address that is the challenge and so so
a lot of what we call content motivation
and this is for a lack of a better word
if you have a way another way of
describing it I'd love to
or articulating it I would love to hear
this is what we think of when we think
about enabling content allowing access
to content but also making decisions
about removal of content content that
could be hate speech that could be
terrorist propaganda that could be
copyright infringement that could be
defamatory statement and that is in the
dispute between two people right that's
a lot of content could create harm it
could create harm for communities for in
the
Jools a harm from one person could be
free speech for another person all of
these decisions are being made by
platforms that are actually facilitating
access it facilitates access to users
and control data on users we've seen
that in the morning session its
facilitate the content itself because
this is either linked from the servers
or actually hosted on the servers and it
facilitate the discriminant
dissemination system right access to the
distribution system it allows us to
connect with one another now the so
these platforms have become a
gatekeepers for or were really
attractive as gatekeepers and that is
something that goes back to the 90s with
the development of the Internet so we
have a regulatory regime that was called
for instance just in the to give an
example the cop the the context of
copyright the DMCA the Digital
Millennium Copyright Act created a
noticin take down regime where you can
actually complain about content that is
allegedly infringing and platform would
have to remove that content if they want
to be immune from liability potential
liability for copyright infringement for
hosting videotapes or pictures that are
that might be infringing copyright but
were uploaded originally by the one of
the users of that platform very soon
after the DMCA and a similar European
regime that created this notice and
takedown we've seen a lot of
technologies that are actually
implementing it so some technologies
were not actually waiting for anyone to
issue a complain but simply filtering
things that are suspected of copyright
infringing in infringement or actually
blocking access right to some members of
the public restricting access so there
are lots of things that are not
mentioned in the law this has also
become a platform for business right and
enabling if you identify content you can
actually monetize it right so platforms
started to be engaged both in enforcing
the law in governance but also in
maximizing the profit that is what they
all about right but this has become a
merged model of actually applying these
to AI has been implemented later on
where we started to have a new form not
just a notice and tag number but take
down and stay down right once we
identified an infringing we can actually
track the system and look for materials
that are similar right similar in the
sense it way they could be identical
that'd be the easiest but they could
also just resemble that file by 30
seconds by 30 minutes by few images etc
so this isn't the copyright context the
more pressure that was put on platforms
more that they had to actually upgrade
their systems in order to address the
regulatory pressure so I think things
that we have seen in the in the
copyright area in the 90s and then in
the first decade of of 2000 we now see
in other types of potentially illicit
contents of the German legislation is a
good example where platforms are
required to remove content within 24
hours this is something that is really
difficult to do if you don't know right
and you sometimes want to prepare
yourself in order not to have to act so
fast another proposal that would require
that if now
that is still being deliberated I
believe and the by the European
Commission and that is a duty to remove
content within one hour that would
definitely require this is not just this
is content that is terrorist propaganda
were allegedly terrorist propaganda and
that has to be removed within one hour
of notice again this you cannot with
insistence of that scale you normally
cannot wait for this to happen and
that's why we see a lot of AI systems
which are actually the ground so we've
seen that the massacre in the in New
Zealand right where of Google and
YouTube were struggling to identify the
videotapes of the massacre in the in the
mosques and and removes them we see
Flickr using AI in order to identify
infringing images and pictures that are
being posted we see a very interesting
this is something that is really this is
a paper I don't think that it's in it
was practice yet but this is quite
remarkable that you know live-streaming
is something that is very difficult to
address and to use machine learning in
order to analyze such that people that
people discussing their plans right and
in chat rooms about a sport game for
instance whether they're going to
livestream
a sports game like a football game and
the UK Premier League right this is
something that has been proven paper but
it just gives you a sense of what you
could do right if you are using machine
learning in order to predict right this
is like what what's the difference
between
this type of predicting policing as well
and live stream of course creates a
challenge because you cannot match it
you cannot say this is the same content
as or even the same once it's live it's
already too late so you want to predict
it ahead of time and of course this is
something that is challenging at various
levels and so what's the problem with
this system the problem is that all this
is happening in an ecosystem that is
completely controlled by the platform so
you have content that is being these are
platform right this supposed to be
interactive right they facilitate access
to user-generated content that is been
uploaded by others so let's see I just
take the copyright an example or the
terrorist propaganda that are being
identified by hashtags or the copyright
example that where you have copyrighted
material that are being identified by
Content ID provided by rightholders you
know so users are the Tees he's jumped
from the airplane and so you have this
input that is been uploaded into the
platform the platform is doing the
screening by AI that is being informed
by the interest of platforms as we've
seen in Content ID for instance right
those minimizing my liability for
copyright infringement or for hate
speech or for terrorist propaganda but
also maximizing my profit if I can
monetize on this so these are the
platform of interest and then we have
the interest of right holders in the
case of copyright or the interest of
governments in the case of of terrorist
propaganda but these interests are being
codified into that screening algorithm
that has to actually do a very simple
task which is classifying between
infringing or non-infringing value now
hate speech or not hate speech right
this is the the type of task and take a
particular action what's more is that
this like every learning every machine
learning system this also feeds back
into the algorithm in Lakes it helps it
identify these contacts contents the
next time so if governments want to
remove for instance
propaganda of Isis that is what they're
gonna get they're gonna get better in
this because that is what they do right
because of that feedback loop even
though there might be some content that
is being removed but it's not about that
right and so just to give their
plaintiff an adult and a lot of
empirical studies which we have done
also at our Center and actually here at
Berkeley I think Jennifer urban which
was doing a lot of empirical work on
looking at the biases created by the
system of automatic removals but this is
just a very this is a recent example of
hard how the the Moller report was being
identified and removed on script just
because it was classified as a
copyrighted material where it cannot be
copyrighted because it is not it was
created by the government right and
governmental be copyrighted to begin
with but that is what the system knows
how to do and that is what it is
removing and it's also bound to be
mistaken just because a lot of these
decisions related to content and whether
this is legal or not illicit or not
infringing or not risky or not depends
on the context and so an excellent study
that was published in 2017 at Princeton
was actually looking in an analyst
these systems that are on the ground
some of it has changed over the past two
years the relative systems are becoming
better in also determining contacts but
as long as there are contextual they
these systems are less reliable so the
reasons we need to have a check on
systems that are doing content
moderation of that sort removing content
based on machine learning systems that
are identifying a listen content one is
efficiency and so we want to have some
quality control we don't want them to be
we don't then we don't want them to
mistakenly remove the molar report we
don't want them to make mistakes in
limiting access to important materials
for public you know in the public sphere
we also are worried about biases and so
we were concerned them in this
ecosystems that is dominated by a
platform and that is removed from any
other site a platform would remove
things that are that coincide with its
own interest are not necessarily with a
social interest there is a problem of
legitimacy and Trust we don't trust a
system that is monolithic right I mean
we always think that there is some sort
of check or some sort of oversight even
if not institutional if it does the
public could say this is outrageous
but when things are removed and we don't
even know that they are removed and even
to communicate that this is outrageous
we need to use a platform it's very
interesting phenomena that people that
were complaining about Facebook
Cambridge analytic crisis we're using
Facebook as they were
doing it you know a lot of studies where
is just showing it's because this is a
platform where yeah we you can actually
communicate but if we don't trust the
system there is a problem of legitimacy
we don't trust this platforms because of
their incentive structure we don't trust
them because they do not provide often
that explanation and a justification for
why they they were acting in one way or
not another but my actually the proposed
the unbaked proposal that I have
actually has to do with this and the
reason I'm less concerned about
efficiency or quality controls it's
because this is the interest of a
platform as well they don't they want to
remove the right thing so if you know
it's a bad thing for them to remove
things that are they after copyright
infringement and their removes things
that are not infringing you know they're
run into problems so so I think that
there are some good incentives in there
the problem of trust become now the
problem of platforms after the hearings
in the Senate a lot of pressure that is
put on platforms in Europe and elsewhere
so I think they're they're looking for
areas where they can actually work
strategies to enhance trust but I think
the problem that I want to focus it is
how do we restrain power this is a
dominant system that is taking making
decisions without any restrain and and
just to give us a reminder we normally
think of two ways of doing this check
and balances right and when we think
about content moderation what should be
removed what should be considered
illegal right an unacceptable speech is
usually defined by the legislature is
being these rules are being implemented
by some executive agencies right that
are looking for these terrorist
propaganda and then there is judicial
review of the executive you know whether
they were acting within their their
authority
relatively we have market competition
right and sometimes we say this platform
is summarizing everything let's move to
another platform but in this market we
don't have that that is one of the
problems if that this market is not
working it's not functioning like other
markets it's a very concentrated market
and so consumers rights you know or a
competition the pressures that would
actually secure our rights as consumers
are less effective and one of the
interesting phenomena is that we see now
in content moderation is actually that
the executive is using exactly this so
that they're using the way in which
platforms are free to remove content in
order to remove content that is less
desirable for government and just you
know there are plenty of examples that I
can give but I think that there in the
recent German law we see that this has
been used and you can look at the data
actually but was provided by YouTube as
you can see that a lot you know that a
lot has been removed you know more in
the more has been reviewed removed based
on Community Guidelines rather than
simply by a request of the government
because this is subject to judicial
review and this is not so okay so the
question is how do we do that and there
are lots of proposals actually in the
literature and I would divide them or I
suggest that we divide them two
regulatory proposals and more
technological tools and in the in
regulation their proposals to insert
more transparency if we have more time
in the Q&A is I will talk of why I think
these are really weak solutions due
process to counter to have a right of
appeal we have that right it almost
never being used an audit in actually
assume that we know what's right and we
actually measure as a platform or the AI
system
say it's working or not right it is it
keeps up but it's its own standards or
the social stance but we don't really
know in these instances or not always
know what's the right way of acting in
technological tools we have attempt to
reconfigure as a system to say you
should take into account fair use we are
going to impose this mere right and then
we will see in auditing whether the
platform is doing this or not or tools
that are more subversive of the that are
actually intend to act to act against
empower users to act against the
circumvent the system and act
differently as a type of protest of some
sort so my proposal is to look at is to
introduce contesting algorithms and what
I mean here and I will quickly go
through this is first - I propose to do
something at the regulatory level and
that is to revise the safe harbor that
we have nowadays is that it is simply
you know you platform gonna be free of
any liability if you comply with noting
it noticin take down my proposal be that
they immunity to the harmful content
that is user-generated content will
apply only if the system also consult a
social system on which I am going to
talk in in a minute
it is also based on computational
dispute resolution this idea of
contesting algorithms and and it
involves a human review at the technical
level we will have this this type of
proposal will require us to or
facilitate the development of a system
that will use machine learning that
would be informed by social values and
not only by the
a platform that the platform now
consider and it would enable a check on
content moderation in real time without
deciding a priori or ex-ante what is the
right solution so the system would be
dynamic so what I mean by that I mean
that we need to create an intervention
so before after the screening and before
the action we have to require platforms
to run that these allegedly infringing
materials on a system that is informed
by social values that could the input
here could be of the rational materials
you know behavior of for instance
nonprofit organizations such as
librarians it could be Court decision
first and foremost for its courts that
have decided particular cases that could
inform the model and and of course the
counter notices of users and and that
system would actually create some sort
of another output right either it would
determine that I use is fair or now
actually what I envision is a system
that would give some sort of a scoring
now
if I have three minutes maybe I'd like
to just pull it together and then
alright so the idea in terms of of the
input that all of this data could be
used to inform the model but what's
going to be new here is that we are
going to have data on the removal itself
so any attempt nowadays to actually
develop systems of that sort didn't have
access to the main data that Google has
that Facebook have now if you--if we are
going to require them to run it through
the system that could be used as one of
the training data and would allow us to
tweak some of these patterns such that
you know that we create this on court
decision or observational data again the
output I envision is more in terms of
scoring and the last point I want to
make is that the system err is going to
allow us to identify what are the social
trade-offs that we have to make right
and so that if the platform for instance
determines or decides what's
infringement is and the social system
can actually come up with some answer
about whether this is 30 percent fair
use or 87 percent fair use or legitimate
use for free speech or facility for some
other reason these two yes are going to
be in conflict and we can decide them so
for the first time we will be able to
actually extract from this monolithic
system with the social trade-offs that
have to be made some of them we can
actually define by the algorithm and so
we can actually transfer to human review
I'm going to leave you with some of the
advantages the idea here is to do a move
from a monolithic system or ecosystem to
a more plural
Takako system banks giving creating a
computational voice to the social
interest from a system that is
completely static in deciding values to
a system that is dynamic and can
actually give or address the monolithic
decision of a platform in real time and
not wait until the court would look at
it in five years time and it creates an
adversary that is not necessarily
correct but it's an alternative to
something that is also not correct right
it just creates an intervention that
simply trying to create a balance by
designing an ecosystem where you have
more dispute than you have today there
are lots of challenges I will list some
of them but I really want to hear and so
I'm gonna stop
[Applause]
sort of a few comments questions first
thing I wanted to do is pull out one of
the points that you made in your talk
that I think just it's such an important
one that we all ought to pay attention
to it so your reference to your work on
the Chilean effects of government use of
data you mentioned that the ways the
data are used and protections we play
put in place for data can change the
content of the data can change the
presence the existence the quality of
that data and I think this is an issue
that is not sufficiently addressed or
pay attention to it would really need to
think of equilibrium effects of an
entire system you can't just put a use
in place you can't put a protection in
place in isolation but there's an entire
data generation and use process that
needs to be analyzing that it's a really
important point I'm not just in this
context but much more broadly and so I
wanted to draw at that point out now
coming to the the contesting algorithms
idea and the particular use case that
you that you analyze in this
presentation first of just a couple of
tricky questions that this raises the
first of these is to who decides what
the goals or interests of society are
there's more than one society there's
more than one group that needs to be
represented in that process
who or what institution I puts in place
these requirements that the platform
needs to check with my authority and
what you do when you have multiple
authorities at the platform needs to
check with and we need to aggravate
their opinions in some way who checks
that the pot for movie is this
requirement how do you have some
transparency to know that as platform is
consulting the societal experts in the
way that they're required to be doing so
are there any technical tools that could
be put in place for platform to certify
that it is following the proto
all that you play it out that it's
really consulting with the algorithm
that it's supposed to be consulting with
it is and set me back a little bit more
it's sort of a challenge to Bennett
folks with the technical background in
the audience what tools could redesign
to ensure that filtering choices are in
some sense made transparent and
accountable to the public there anything
that we could do to force my platforms
to basically have a paper trail and some
way to make that process visible and
audible one concern is that a process
that only requires sort of a check when
the platform wants to remove content or
block content is only solving the
problem in one direction what about the
content that the platform should have
filtered but didn't and that seems like
a hard problem you focused for a very
good reason on the stuff that I want to
take down because that's a small
percentage of the content but we really
need to check someplace for all the
content so how do you handle that it
seems like a real challenge I like the
idea of contesting algorithms it
reminded me of sort of work in
adversarial machine morning we see the
sort of theme that we built the system
that we don't really understand
good-looking build another system that
we don't really understand in order to
improve it and I think that sort of
thinking that way is is really
interesting and I wanted to sort of at
the last point I to just sort of wonder
are there other ways that we can use
that perspective to help in this problem
setting so I mean as you mentioned
auditing is a really sort of fraught and
limited tool for putting controls in
place and for one reason for this is
that we don't have access to ground
truth we don't generally know what the
great things to take down are the wrong
things to take down if we didn't have
access to ground truth maybe we could do
something cool where we can have an
algorithm that is an auditing algorithm
that you could put in place that
actually could test the system well what
would you do with this content well what
would you do with that content it could
catch the algorithm disobeying some
ground truth or some societal norms and
I wonder if that that idea can be played
with even when we don't have ground
truth some idea of a contesting
algorithm that's actually interacting
more sort of interactively with the the
filtering algorithm and is really trying
to push it to its boundary cases perhaps
just to expose to the public what those
boundary cases look like you know here
are the hard calls somehow maybe not
something that we should be aware of and
so I just I wondered whether or not this
perspective you're taking might might be
useful it's actually the same questions
who decides you know what is you
mentioned the Christchurch mosque I'm a
New Zealand
it's a much
so yeah I think these are excellent
questions and actually not another I
have answers I really like the idea of
government intervention has become
tested I agree with everything but we
need to so that's why first of all I
think that is why it's important to have
a lot of strategies and I think for
these types of tools I think you know
that to counteract power that is not
depending on government is important but
I think it's not enough because this is
you know I think this is the echo system
that we now have is really is really
monolithic this is really bad for free
speech and it's vulnerable for
governmental of use as well I think in
terms of the question who decide these
social values I'm not this is not I
don't think of it as
redefining society to begin with this is
something that we have you know we each
live in a country where we have a social
contract maybe we don't like it but this
is our social culture in this country
free speech is supposed to stop mr.
Trump from you know decisions that you
have described and in New Zealand free
speech would be different right yeah I
mean that's true it's it's absurd but
this is a social contract right and so I
think that this should comply with the
social contract in terms of our social
contract values the question of who is
represented here it's goes into the
details and I think that does who
represented here should be the
externalities of this those who are not
represented here so we have a criteria
who decides who applies the criteria you
know again I wouldn't invent the
reinventing the state we have
institutions that decide these things
you know whether you it if it would be a
good question to ask right whether we
want to have a committee a judiciary
committee that would do that whether who
is doing the balancing and that may
change from one country to another
depending on our constitutional
framework but I think that these are the
steps to be taken
and I think that is and I think that
these values may change from again in
some countries that would be one set a
fee but but I think what the as a
framework this could also change over
time it's not that they have the whole
idea that it should be a way of deciding
values and not a way of applying us to a
fixed set of values
because we often get these questions who
decides it's not a question it's not a
it's a question that it's not as if you
said oh no I shouldn't decide it's gonna
be left unanswered if it's left
unanswered then it's gonna be the
platform to this life it's not as if no
one's to sign it so so I think that I
mean you where your answer is exactly
right but it's to say that someone is
deciding already and now we need to
counterbalance it in any which way that
that brings some Faris spread of values
to the table
just another I think is very interesting
and I think one way to think about the
institutional design which you think is
what we're talking about now in order to
make this work
he's trying to draw upon some
experiences in Co regulation that we
seen some jurisdictions currently on the
ground so for example we heard earlier
this morning about advertisements in the
UK what they did is because they didn't
want the government to decide in the
definitely didn't want the other type of
agencies to decide they set up this
regulatory body that is its own
deficiencies of course any agency part
one any agencies
generate agency problems but what's
interesting about that is that they set
up juries that are comprised of however
you want to either and there are ways to
test out the compressor and what's nice
about Yuri do you think is that you can
run simulations because you don't have
ground reality but you can have some
proxy of what juries that are subject to
certain extent a letí's would think
about those kind of issues and is the
more you run the simulations that you
can you can edit into the feedback crew
in terms of contesting contesting
decisions of platforms or off government
so if you see it as a triad you know you
had government yet platform but then you
have some input from civil society if
you structure it in certain way then you
can shift the burden of proof you can
ship the owners to say well why don't
you justify your decision because they
actually have an input on what on what
those suffering from a schematic view
that to be so if you shift the burden
then then you can then you can at least
get more meaningful integration make
sure I understand someone argument so
I'm curious like how important it is
that some of this is automated or that
it's decided by algorithms like if if we
reach the same exact if the platform's
we're reaching the exact same decisions
with some human led deliberative process
with the argument being different or is
it that like it's because the platforms
are basically monopolies and therefore
control so much of our interactions with
each other that is sort of the main
problem like a lack of accountability
with respect to any kind of subjective
decision-making plus sort of having
almost total control of a particular
market those two meet seem to be the
ingredients which cause us to be
concerned less maybe algorithms before
perhaps I've misunderstood no I think
well first of all I think this is a very
good point and I think that every time I
come to work in these areas that relate
to a platform algorithms and data it's
very difficult to distinguish and I
agree with you it's really important to
distinguish in this particular instance
the problem arise from the fact that
this is a I base rather than rule base
because if we had rules it would have
made it easier for instance Facebook has
a Community Guidelines this this is
governance by rules right and you can
you can challenge the rules you can
challenge them for instance in European
countries or you know you Israel
included here as or as under standard
contract regime you can say or contract
offered region here in the United States
you can actually you have the tools when
it is done by AI the decisions about
each particular removal you know it's
not based necessarily on these rules
right it's it's a sort of an
interpretation you know of rules that is
codified it's dynamic it doesn't have
the same transparency
it is not ex-ante it depends on the
training data and on the feedback loop
and we don't have a system to address it
because we have consumers rights or we
have in a constitutional framework but
it doesn't fit the problem so that's why
I think it makes a difference in this I
just worried that like even in cases
where we have humans doing these like
very upsetting low level content
moderation decisions by hand and even
though they've been given this very
detailed guide about how to make these
decisions of course they're gonna be
subjective of course they're going to
like have like a their own limited
training data right like they're gonna
have a right particular way of thinking
about the problem given what they've
been exposed to and I'm just still not
completely sure like if there's
something profoundly more challenging
about algorithms then even having this
process done in this high that you
should be the way with lots of people
and lots of process so let me just give
an example so when we have decisions
about who in a predictive policing rate
we could be racist the system could be
racist police officers could also be
racist but then we have a way of
addressing it or at least a framework
maybe not successful but we can actually
take that police officer to court and
question them and show that in his
behavior before you druing in after he
was racist and so but what do you do as
a system right how do you you have to
create a process by which you establish
this or litigate it to challenge this
and I think it's more complicated and
because it's dynamic because it is not
ex-ante because it's not transparent
[Music]
two less quick formats for ya so over I
just want to say first day I really
appreciated your talking Thanks
yeah so my question is you're motivated
by this sort of issue of the mono listen
the monolithic Facebook and YouTube and
so on but what do you think about the
concerns that we keep adding more and
more regulations and barriers to jump
that it will be impossible for
competitors to ever arise because they
need to start from somewhere and so
we're stuck into this model it's a huge
problem I agree and actually one of the
benefits from this ecosystem but at
least it creates a market here that is
an on Facebook market because I mean if
we ask Facebook to take fair use into
account or YouTube that be that becomes
even you know more you know stronger
right but this should be independent
that's the whole idea that the system
even not perfect should be independent
of this there should be adversary and I
think that creates a market here for
independent software that could be
afterwards she could be used also by
librarians could be used by could be
used in non platform context to identify
algorithmically you know these trade
offs
landed at 8 a.m. this morning after 15
hours of flying so my question to you is
it seems that in in your in your view of
the world law kind of stands us today
where is this computation foundation I
hope I'm not that stealing me rate
spikes here law might be transformed
itself right and I think also Julie
wondering where is the change in the law
Wednesday I wonder how we came to this
point I usually do privacy research but
I've been looking at you know the
machine learning then very surprised
that a lot of the research has focused
on adversarial machine learning where
the service provider is benevolent
people it's coming from the outside but
we haven't had this model question and
you know Katrina did a great job of how
you could literally reverse the roles
and say what happens when the person
service service provider is what kind of
tools can we give to the users to escape
the wrath of the machine right and I'm
just wondering if we can maybe think
about contestable machine learning or
corporate of machine learning which is
not so centralized like even today when
we think about that machine learning
it's not the service of a centralized
service provider or maybe we do it I
would love the citations that looks at
another multi-party computation but like
collective corporate machine when did we
stop thinking about open source and
write and develop communities of
developers yeah this is a great question
about the law I think this is an
excellent question and I and I've been
thinking about this is once we take for
in in their view that the social system
could be informed by court decision
actually assume that this is actually
going to be processed right on an
ongoing basis
so you know the balances of hate speech
and free speech infringement and
copyright and that actually you know may
change the role of courts I think courts
that are functioning in this environment
may have to undertake a different role
can they make decisions against what the
machine learning model is producing
under what circumstances what type of
overview they they could you know
whatever tools for them in order to I
mean they have to oversight this as well
right sometimes especially when there
are these trade-offs to be made you know
in you know when I think that this is
this is changing the role of courts but
it could also change substantially the
you know with what the rules are right
what the trade-offs are right and I
think that the whole I think the idea of
this system is to create a space for
this it's not that I I know you know I
don't think that any one of us know what
the right balance is we just know that
there should be more diversity and the
way we decide let's say speaker in
during months or more questions over
coffee